hola que tal buenas noches empecemos por
contar que por supuesto todas las
figuras públicas de la argentina de la
política del espectáculo y por supuesto
del deporte y del mundo salieron a
manifestar su pesar por la muerte de
diego armando maradona y como bien
señalaba en muchos puntos de argentina
específicamente de la ciudad de buenos
aires- se están viendo concentraciones
como esta en la puerta del estadio de
boca juniors el club que no fue si se
quiere el primer lugar donde jugó dio
armando maradona el otro club donde está
concentrando gente de argentinos suyos
donde comenzó su carrera pero sin duda
su gran amor futbolístico fue boca y
boca siempre ha querido llamado a diego
armando maradona y canas y celebrando
con gritos con aplausos con cantos
vistiendo la camiseta de boca vistiendo
la camiseta de argentina la figura de
diego armando maradona es una
combinación de pesar de tristeza y de
emoción por lo que represento a la
figura de maradona lo mismo se ve aquí
en el estadio de argentinos suyos que
lleva el nombre de diego armando
maradona y también en el obelisco en el
centro de la capital
y así se van despidiendo empezando a
despedirse los seguidores los amantes de
la figura de maradona esto continuará el
día jueves a las 8 de la mañana
aproximadamente con las de la despedida
el velorio que tendrá lugar en la casa
rosada- la casa de gobierno de la
argentina el gobierno puso a disposición
de la familia y de todos los seguidores
de maradona este espacio público para la
despedida del astro futbolístico
argentino a partir de ahí veremos
todavía no sabemos bien cómo va a seguir
cuáles van a ser los siguientes pasos
dónde será enterrado y armando maradona
estamos esperando la confirmación de
cómo se irá este devenir pero
ciertamente las despedidas no se
terminan ni hoy ni el jueves esto
continuará varios días gracias a natalio
por este reporte desde la ciudad de
buenos aires- concentraciones
espontáneas de seguidores de ciudadanos
argentinos que quieren rendir tributo a
diego armando maradona